what's up everyone
i am pumped to talk to you guys about
zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance by robert pearsig
i'm super grateful that one of my best
friends greg
carner had read the book and passed it
along to me as a birthday gift recently
and it was definitely one of the best
books i've ever read it's actually
known as one of the best selling
philosophy books of all time
also as one of the most widely read
philosophy books
ever there have been millions and
millions and millions of copies sold
worldwide across 23 different languages
and it's kind of funny because robert
after
having 121 different rejections
uh ended up landing this as such a
popular philosophy book i think one of
the reasons why
it ended up being so popular is because
he had
a lot of breadth studying philosophy
also he had an iq of 170
which is one in about 50 000 people
have that he graduated high school at
age 14. 14
and he was interested in science itself
rather than any
professional career path so basically in
trying to understand what the essence of
philosophy
science the nature of reality are
rather than following a career path in
in the actual economic machinery itself
and i think that one of the reasons why
he was so successful also was because
that he follows a a rhythm in his
writing
that is of one of the highest cadences
that i've ever
kind of took taken in it only took me
about three days
and he weaves together the biggest
philosophical questions
with within this 17-day motorcycle
cross-country adventure with his son and
in the first couple of days
he was with his uh two other friends
and so that's kind of uh
one of the ways that he makes it
relatable is that he's able to weave in
these most complex philosophical
questions
in with uh something as
as simple as a motorcycle cross-country
adventure it makes it more relatable
so i would like to just pop things off
and just start it off with this question
what is
best what is quality
and a lot of what we have going on in
our civilization
is we have a a non-focus
on those questions if you think about it
in school
did you ever have a time that a teacher
or another student
around you asked you those questions
what is
best or what is quality
because if we don't have our society
pressing us to figure out what those
things
are the likelihood that we just become
cogs in the machinery increases so
that's why those questions are so
important so maybe rather than
asking one of your friends when you see
them again you know hey
what's new instead of asking them that
try asking them
yo what do you think is best and just
see where that conversation leads you
so i'm gonna go ahead and wander into
what is the most
upstream issue so the downstream we have
today's
church of reason and economic machinery
and things like that which have done
good jobs in many ways
but also have their own malevolences
that we'll talk about but i'm gonna head
upstream for a moment
so if you think about consciousness if
you think about awareness if you think
about perception
these are the most fundamental
characteristics of
experience of phenomenology there's
nothing more fundamental than your
consciousness than my consciousness than
our
consciousness than this awareness
nothing is more fundamental than that
and so because of that we are
we are in deep
need to understand what it is
that's why it's basically this pinnacle
of metaphysics
this pinnacle of synthesis between
science and spirituality is
consciousness
is awareness in the studying of that and
understanding it
what robert did a good job of explaining
was what happened
with emmanuel kant and what happened was
that a similar to what
nicholas copernicus did when he
identified that
it's not the earth that's the center of
the universe but that the earth
orbits around the star that our sun
that there was this big sort of shift
in perspective and consciousness that
occurred slowly but it took a little bit
of time and kant did
a similar thing where he said that it's
not just this blank slate
that were born with this blank slate but
rather there is something called
a priori and a priori can just
simply be thought of as the 3.5
billion years of biological evolution
that we went through before getting to
this point
so meaning from a single celled organism
understanding sensing its environment
right so that's where we had
people like james cook on our show that
was talking about the
the sort of internal consciousness
understanding
of keeping some sort of a ledger of an
environment right and having that style
of
of balance between that so a sensing of
an environment and making decisions
based on that
and so from that moment of the initial
cell on the planet all the way up
through the development of the
multicellular organism
all of the cambrian explosion and the
different sea creatures
all the way up to when they come on to
land all the way up through the
reptilian era through the dinosaur era
the asteroid collision the chimpanzee
and then the human that there was this
deep
deep process of building up these
biological a priorities
and that's why when a mouse that has
never seen a cat before
and this is clear in scientific
literature it gets even just
the scent or the hair of a cat near it
it fear response and runs away so there
is this lineage of epigenetics
for mice that have been stacking up
over time and it's similar with us
as well that's why when we think about
this a priori
we wonder is good built into it
is quality built into our a priori
do we inherently know what
is good and what is not
and then then is it up to that free will
to make the decision to head towards the
good on an individual level
on manifesting our destiny into the
world and our
unique gift into the world and our
highest moral potential and also on a
collective level
for us to as a civilization head head
towards what is the
most benevolent future trajectory for
us for all of us and rather than
something that's more
malevolent and so that sort of idea of
unpacking
what is our a priori perceptual
infrastructures that exist and another
way of kind of understanding this is
music
right you hear these these beautiful
tunes and rhythms and
and melodies and harmonics and singing
and
orchestras and symphonies and that's why
when you hear bach or beethoven or
mozart
that your entire body gets chill sent
through you and that's why they're
known as the top composers of
all time and that's why you go there
instead of listening to somebody just
like
scraping uh on a violin
randomly right and so
this is the idea you have an inherent
perceptual ability to sense
good and to sense quality and
that ability may even be
ultimate reality which we'll get to
towards
the end and
so just the unpacking of that is its own
that's its own book and that's its own
documentary and that's its own and we're
going to be working on projects like
that that really begin
unpacking what that a priori uh
awareness infrastructure
is that is then
basically parsing
our world for what the star is at all
times
and that's why right when you hear the
music you can
sense it but you it's not a logical
reasoning thing you after you
sense it then you break down logically
oh well mozart is incredible because of
x y and z so it's an a priori
snap to sensation of the good into
of quality and uh and not so much
of the downstream is the reasoning part
of it more so
and that's why the greek had the word
arete for
excellence and that the more that
we sort of commune with what
these ancient spiritual wisdoms are
the more we commune with those that are
basically
dead um the more that we really begin to
understand like what can i pull
from like the ancient egyptians and the
and the mesopotamians and the indus
valley and and the vedas and zoroaster
and
and judaism and christianity and islam
and
and buddhism and hinduism and and
taoism and confucianism and the african
voldun traditions
and the native americans and shamanism
and plant medicines and that style of
indigenous wisdom
what can we basically begin pulling from
them as a pattern of how they
how they understood and embodied some
sort of a metaphysical good
or quality into their spirit and lives
and how they basically leveraged that
in order to live lives that were
more towards that good in quality as we
saw in the greek
in many people say that the greek
civilization
was actually one of the peaks
of philosophy that we've ever had and i
completely agree with that
and there's some sort of a strange there
was no division between good and truth
is what we think this is a very
interesting subject
but then all of a sudden truth won over
good
and that's why we led to the world of
reason and sort of the aristotelian
division of everything rather than that
platonic sort of good one ideology
and there's a synthesis that needs to
happen between the two
where you can have truth and reason and
science
and technology be synthesized with
quality good values
that style of thinking art and
spirituality and that's basically one of
the key essences of my life
and it's a key essence of of chapter
seven the sorting algorithm of
high-level perception that will be
published here in a couple weeks
and that style of thinking of the
synthesis
of these two sort of dominating
ways of perception and feeling and
embodying
and being and catalyzing
advancements in the world is basically
one of the most
critical essences that we need to do in
order to most properly move forward so
that's basically what a big chunk of
what robert was writing about was was
that the
reason lacks values it lacks that
quality
and that that's causing all of these
other downstream issues in our 20th
century
in the 20th century we experienced as
nietzsche said the death of god
and we experienced 150 million or so
deaths due to that secularization due to
that nihilism
due to the dropping of that pinnacle
starve the highest possible morality
there was not so much of the embodiment
of atlas and buddha and
christ and there was more so the
embodiment of
some sort of possession of
of of a secularization in it as max
wieber says a disenchantment
and that sort of desacralization ended
up
catalyzing a lot of the malevolence
downstream that happened with the
holocaust
and with the uh the gulag
and with the great leap forward and
shine in with pol pot
and with the the armenian greek and
assyrian genocide
that that these these types of
malevolences are very specifically
honed from the uh from the most
upstream issue of sort of reason not
having
a a heart and a value an equality
uh or an understanding of the good and i
think that's super duper important for
us to have
identified and today in the 21st century
people feel like cogs in the economic
machinery
and this is a big problem with what we
see
in in places in modernity like like
china is that they have a lot of
communistic
social fabric success with eradicating
poverty and whatnot and giving people
more but they also have the problem of
people losing their individuality and
feeling more like a cog in a machine
um as a replaceable cell in the organism
of china
and that that's also a big problem but
the united states also has their big
problems with the
over individualization to such a point
where
the uh lack of sort of um of social
fabric
infrastructures becomes sort of
secondary
and thinking that that's actually not as
important for actualizing the basic
needs of every single person and so
that's sort of an
understanding as well in the sorting
algorithm it's not just of science and
spirituality that need to be sorted and
uplifted
but also of the left and the right
domestically in the us
of nationally on an international level
the us and china being able to sort
these
best practices into a synthesis at the
the
highest possible that that can be
unleashed into the world getting rid of
the disenchantments
and maximizing the potential of a
synthesis
of of reason with quality so
science also has a hierarchy of facts it
was really interesting learning more
about jules henry
poincare i actually hadn't really come
across his work too much but
he's a massive massive influence on
understanding that science actually has
a hierarchy of facts itself
and that's where there's you can begin
seeing that actually science itself
has a um has quality to it as well
so there's a star in science as well and
a good way to think about this is
that it's it's more efficient for you to
learn a very general truth in science
than it is for you to learn some sort of
like something way lower on the pyramid
on the hierarchy like something that's
only specific to the niche of one
specific or
uh species right so if i know the
behavioral
drive of a single species in biology
that's less important than if i know how
a cell works
and you can understand that the cell
general truths of
a cell and of proteins are way more
important because they're applicable
across the biological kingdom and
spectrum than us the single behaviors
of one species and so you can see there
is beginning to be some sort of a
hierarchy
of facts and science as well so that's
where you can kind of start beginning to
see some sort of a synthesis
and it's also very true we talked about
this before on the show as well
is that in science if you don't have
values and quality uh and spirituality
that enter into science you have
problems like
the the robert oppenheimer edward teller
sort of
atomic bomb hydrogen bomb era that
became unleashed
and because of that death of god but
then at the same time if you don't have
science enter into the realm of
spirituality
then you have people that are trying to
peddle things like
snake oil salesmen you have people that
where there's
we need the scientific test to be able
to tell if that sort
of uh
that claim that these things are
energetically healing
that we can scientifically verify those
claims
so yeah we've talked about this quite a
bit we need to
you know robert talked about it as a
classical the classical being the
science and the technology
and the reason and then the romantic
being the arts
and the quality and the spirituality
and the values and we need a synthesis
between those
uh and that's going to maximize our
potential and that every single
our our social fabric itself needs to be
conducive
maximally conducive incentive wise and
inspiration wise
to have every single person realize that
they're gonna have the most meaning come
into their lives
by taking on the most burden on their
back as in the more responsibility
like jordan peterson has been talking
about the more you're like atlas
right in mythology the more you're like
christ the more you're like buddha the
more you
eradicate the roots of your own
suffering
through understanding the breath and
understanding the consciousness and
awareness
and the more that you sort of take on
the biggest moral burdens on yourself
the more that you're gonna feel like
you're achieving a higher level of
existence and being
and the more that you're going to feel
like you're heading towards the north
star right we have to
we have to head towards something we
have to future author
our way so it's a balance between being
here and in the now
and being super present with also being
super oriented towards the future
and being honed in on that relentlessly
and so it's that balance as well
and you basically begin treating good as
a noun
rather than an adjective and that this
becomes the highest moral conduct of all
and i think that's really profound and
and robert unpacked that more in his
second book leela
lila an inquiry into morals that was
written in 1991 whereas
zam zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance and in green the values was
written in 1974.
so i also want to
remember just remember that last part
that last part so crucial that you have
to think about good as a noun
rather than an adjective and the more
that you think about that the more you
realize that it really is
like a sort of set of behaviors and
principles
and and objects and ideas and
ideals that i have to sort of think
about and embody and work with us
super frequently in order to have that
highest moral conduct
um another problem that happened in the
book well
that i think was one of the biggest
problems that super identifies to modern
society
is that uh we took this 170 iq genius of
of robert who was you know phaedras at
that time
and he was you know very brilliant as
you know professing in in english and he
was he was recognizing that rather than
teaching his students what quality was
that he should be having them understand
what quality is themselves
and so that was one of the profound
realizations and then
started building out this whole idea of
a metaphysics of quality
and then there was this sort of decision
that oh well he's actually
insane and then because of that decision
and because of the time period that it
was in that
we could do things like do this electro
convulsive therapy
onto him and basically
barbecue him and to await
that personality into a new personality
that's a huge problem
that's a huge problem it's not you can't
do that anymore today
involuntary stuff like that you can't do
that anymore today against the law
but it is something to think about is
that level of neurodiversity if we have
these people that are three standard
deviations above the mean and iq and
more and they're genius visionaries we
need to
we need to be highly conducive to
helping them with storytellers and with
and with teams and with
further dissemination tools that allow
them to
actualize their technologies and their
stories into the center of the bell
curve that then
kind of move everybody up this is a big
part of chapter four called portals and
high level perception and
that that sort of essence is going to be
critical rather than taking that
neurodiversity
and just throwing it off to the side
like it's insanity
and then we lose their gifts so that's
that was a very profound
point for me as well there are these
basically there's these patterns of the
most uncommon 1 billion people that have
ever lived out of the 100 billion people
that have lived that we have the
civilizational
inheritance from and the 99 billion
common people that have lived
don't have as many of these patterns
that the one billion really uncommon
people do that have basically made
the world that we live in today and so
we need to identify what those patterns
are and amplify them more
for everybody and that the sort of in
the bucket of frogs example the center
of this evolutionary pacer can't be
pulling down these genius level frogs
that are trying to escape
out of the bucket and help other people
move forward
and that's what we have with these like
resentment and and
and jealousy and envy that happens in
that center of the
of the bell curve so
all right i'll move into some of the
last things here so
i think that one of the most profound
things that
uh especially jordan peterson has been
teaching about has been this idea that
it's quite possible that a
a metaphysics an understanding of how we
got to where we are today
is through an idea of
that uh if you think about back to the
age of chimpanzees slowly evolving
into the sort of prehistoric humans
what what happened was there was a
moment of
of sex sexual selection that occurred
where
it became more and more clear that that
women
had the choice of declining
men in the hierarchy and so
that made men more self-conscious so
basically it made
men more aware of
their place in the hierarchy it made
them more aware
of their behavioral patterns so women
declining
men in sexual selection uh made men more
self-conscious and so it
made women more self-conscious and it
made us together more
aware so that was potentially this is an
idea
it was potentially the birth of
metacognition so sexual selection may
have birthed
metacognition and then metacognition
may have given rise to what is good it
may have given rise to values it may
have given rise to quality
and so that idea of metacognition
sort of enabling the bifurcation of what
is good and what is
bad is another profound idea that it's
possible that we then realize that i can
use my free will
in order to decide to make good moves to
climb up this hierarchy of competence
and then the higher i am on the
hierarchy of competence the more likely
i am
to propagate my genes moving forward
with a very high level
female player a very profound idea
and then even downstream from that is
that these ideas
so basically we took our metacognition
and we took the ideas of
values and quality and what is good and
we put those into stories
and so then those stories we put on you
know the big cave paintings from 30
000 years ago we put them into we wrote
them on papyrus on stone
and we began telling these stories
orally through traditions over these
tens of thousands of years
and the idea is that those that were
better
rhetoricians those that used
the essences of persuasion of
ethos logos pathos
the more that you can talk from a place
of authority from a place of logic from
a place of emotional persuasion
when you tell stories the more your
memes
will communicate into the other person's
receiving genes and then that person
will take their genes and be able to
more successfully propagate them
downstream so storytelling became
one of the most critical aspects
of our evolutionary history and it was
really the ability to take
quality what is good what is value
and put it into like a compression
algorithm into these stories
and that's a big that's the that is the
old testament basically
and that the more that you realize that
you know abel made that massive
sacrifice
and that cain made that horrible
decision of killing
abel in that resentment and jealousy
that his sacrifice wasn't as good the
more that you
see that and embody that and realize
that and understand that
the more your genes are able to
propagate at a higher level because you
understand
what is at the top of that sort of idea
of values and quality and what is good
and so we've been passing that down for
tens of thousands of years now
and it's a really interesting
evolutionary story arc if it's
true but at the same time there was this
there was this really good uh there was
this really good
quote that was that was said by
by robert in
in the book as well um that it was
something along the lines of
like that uh phaedra's
uh do we really need to know what is do
we really need someone to tell us what
is good and what is
not and i think that that is also a
really good
uh really good idea as well is that do
you really need these
so it's this balance between needing
these sort of stories over tens of
thousands of years
and also understanding that you have
this a priori infrastructure
that enables you to sense what is good
and of high quality so it's a balance
between those two things
and then sort of you know kind of
rounding it off at the very end i'd like
to say that i think that
the idea of robert's metaphysics of
quality
is super duper interesting and it's very
possible that
as he says that it's possible that
quality is maybe actually
ultimate reality quality might be
that sort of a priori filter that we
have on our
awareness that sort of gives rise to
those immediacies and consciousness the
first ones that we sort of
become aware of that that may in fact be
ultimate reality that may be god it may
be
dao it may be the brahmin it may be uh
it may be the essence of of ultimate
reality
and if that's true then
it could imply it at a deeper
uh darwinian metaphysical level and not
just
at an individual level meaning that
it's not only important that you with
your individual decisions
become christ-like buddha-like
the highest level of morality possible
through
a synthesis of both your own a priority
essences
but also through understanding these
deep literatures of tens of thousands of
years
but also that every single decision that
you make
actually has to do with the destiny of
the cosmos at a deeper level
so meaning that your decisions butterfly
effect out into civilization
and then civilization's trajectory goes
towards that fork
as well of if civilization's going to
make it
in our next big steps or if it's not and
so that's the
sort of darwinian metaphysical level is
that
in order for us to get to the next sort
of uh
potentially what i hypothesize in in
chapter 10 called
infinity in the book that it's possible
that
what we are as ultimate reality is that
consciousness exploring infinity
and that as robert pearson says is that
that quality
a priori filter that we have on that is
also ultimate reality
in the sense that our free will decision
making
of going towards the good or going
towards the bad
that is a that synthesized with
the darwinian metaphysical level if
we're going to make it to our
consciousness exploring infinity to the
next recursion
is very important in so every single
decision that we make
has to do with that trajectory if we're
going to make it the snake eating its
tail the oroboro symbol
are we going to make it in the way we do
that as via john smart's
transition hypothesis meaning we
actually go inward
through the the vr the neural
prosthetics the
ai age the agi age that it's a synthesis
of all the simulation theory
technologies
that exist and that soon will have uh
in an infinite amount of new universes
that we'll be able to transcend into
and that will be like this in the candy
store is just chocolate
and that as donald hoffman says is that
we're going into vanilla
and strawberry and mango and cookies and
cream and all the new flavors
of consciousness ice cream that we'll be
tasting that may not be these
these four limbed two eyed
carbon based dna encoded creatures of
consciousness
but rather different soul vehicles in
those
next recursions so we may be using
different soul vehicles in the next
recursions
but in order to get there you need to
think about this metaphysics of quality
at your own moment to moment decision
level chapter two is called
seed theory in high level perception and
i talk a lot about the bifurcations that
exist every single one of those
bifurcations you need to think about
and really open up your heart to can i
be
good at this bifurcation instead of
reacting
to this stimulus that's trying to get me
to be bad that's trying to get me to
name call back at someone that's trying
to get me to hit someone
that's trying to get me to be violent or
malevolent what if
i instead take the moral burden on my
back and make the good decision to stay
calm
and to stay loving and to stay
compassionate and then to watch that
anger
and malevolence dissipate in that other
person
we're triggered with these things all
the time but it's up to us
to have that high level of metacognition
and to realize that these things
are happening to us and for us to aim in
that direction
of the highest metaphysical good of that
metaphysics of quality
of values of what is good but also at
the highest darwinian level that we got
to make it as
a as a civilization you can think about
it as one
cellular organism that really wants to
divide
to undergo mitosis the whole planet but
that our little cell cycle our cell
checkpoint
that we have to get to that checkpoint
in order to divide and to go into the
recursion
but in order to get there all of the
little organelles
inside of the cell all the different
nations and all the different molecules
like
us individuals need to have a high level
of intracellular communication
in order to be able to get to that cell
checkpoint and to undergo mitosis and to
go through the recursive process into
the next
flavors in the infinite candy store that
we're exploring
so maybe that consciousness is exploring
infinity
and it's a big unbounded map and we're
forever doing that
and that your metaphysics of quality
your values your determining of what is
good with your free will
determines how successful we are
at achieving both our individual goals
and our collective destiny
so every single decision you make has to
do
with the telos of the cosmos
that's a big thing that's a big thing
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in
um i'm super grateful for robert
piersick he passed about three years ago
in in 2017. um i highly recommend
reading zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance he's
i think he's one of the best synthesis
that uh has been around in
a long time and uh yeah he was it's one
of the best books i mean he really does
a strong job at
uh synthesizing all the perennial
philosophy but also at putting it in a
really beautiful motorcycle adventure
story at the same time
and so i highly recommend reading it
i'll put a link in the bio to it so you
guys can check it out
and then his other book leela as well
leela and inquiry into morals
check that out as well um that kind of
goes a little
bit deeper onto his metaphysics of
quality he has a there's a couple people
online that are talking about it as well
uh that you can find it's moq
metaphysicsofquality.org moq.org i'll
put that link in the bio too
check some stuff out again ask people
what is best
instead of what is new really start
asking that question what is
best also what is quality start asking
people those big questions
thanks jace appreciate the comment about
awesome talk shout out to you
shout out to you guys thank you so much
for tuning in
i'm super grateful for our audience that
we have it's still at the early stages
guys we have about 75k
subs after about three years of going
hard at this
and still the early stages we're about
to blow up i'm about to publish this big
synthesis
it's super explained like i'm five it's
super visual it's super beautiful and
super short
i'm pumped for you guys to all take that
in and then for us to talk about our
next chapter because uh the next chapter
is huge and it's a big surprise for you
and you'll see where that's going um in
about less than about less than a month
you'll see where
uh where we took the next chapter and
how we're getting at the throat of the
awakening and how we're moving things
forward at
a bigger level so i love you all very
much
um big love to robert pierce zen in the
art of motorcycle maintenance check that
out
and godspeed to all of you as well on
your north star
journeys and uh
crush it crush it guys we got this big
love
comment subscribe share the video if you
found it enriching
you guys know what to do biggest of love
peace